enfin dernier élément que nous verserons
ce soir à ce dossier les ikastola des
écoles ce sont des écoles basques il y
en a dans une vingtaine de communes du
pays basque elle accueille aujourd'hui
600 enfants de 2 à 13 ans et ils
reçoivent la un enseignement en langue
basque mais voilà ces écoles privées
traverse des difficultés financières
alors elles demandent d'être intégré
dans le système d'enseignement public
avec ton barré avec la main
j'ai deux petits bijoux qu'ils jouent
aux cow boy qui soit à l'école ou dans
la rue les élèves des ikastola joue avec
les deux langues comme avec leurs deux
mains par son idée du nécessaire
équilibre entre la connaissance de l'une
et de l'autre d'un environnement
essentiellement francophone la première
étape des ikastola la maternelle axe
toute sa pédagogie sur l'acquisition de
ce qu'ils considèrent comme leur langue
maternelle le basque je suis basque et
tous les boss qui n'ont pas pris la fuit
réellement leur langue à la maison on se
sent très frustré et j'avais ça faisait
longtemps que j'avais décidé de la
prendre et j'avais décidé pour mes
enfants qu'il ne ferait pas la même
démarche que moi c'est à dire qu'ils
parlent que leur langue maternelle
serait le basque le pays basque est une
contrée où de culture de langue se
côtoient et nous considérons que pour
chacune de ces langues
le système scolaire doit être adaptée or
jusqu'à maintenant
pour alan le basque il n'y avait pas de
système scolaire adapté il n'était pas
prévu de faire un enseignement en basse
le projet des ikastolas et cela c'est
que finalement nous mettions sur pied
une école adaptée à la langue basque et
à la culture basque en ce véhicule civil
et j'ai de toute culture qu'est l'école
la plupart des matières des matelas lits
sur sont enseignés dans la langue du
pays de la maternelle à la 5e bientôt
jusqu'à la troisième 600 enfants depuis
1969 date de la première ikastola
contribuer de fait à refaire de cette
langue une langue vivante
pour l'instant jean s'échangent entre
ses membres pour les mathématiques en
basque j'ai les enseignes comme comme si
je les emmenais en france est simplement
dans une autre langue
le problème se situe ailleurs bon niveau
des traditions pour moi c'est de me fait
un travail supplémentaire et au niveau
des enfants n'ont pas de livres
thématiques
le basque doit être l'enseignement une
langue disons d'utilité courante mais il
faut qu'elle puisse devenir une langue
et études
depuis toujours nous demandant à être
une école publique c'est un peu le le
contre courant de l'école privée
finalement nous ne voulons absolument
pas être école privée non volantes être
écoles publiques basse pour l'instant
l'ikastola fonctionne comme une école
privée puisque les parents verse 3 % de
leur salaire à l'école mais la non
reconnaissance des ikastola par les
services publics donnent un certain
mêmes jeunes des inquiétudes pour
l'avenir
pourquoi tu ne pas rester si elle cacher
parce que le soleil va que jusqu'à un 3e
étape que ça s'arrête difficile rentrée
ça leur fait une salle santé maintenance
oui mais c'était parents qui se veulent
un peu ce toit les parents ils m'ont
laissé choisir mais la situation
difficile des ikastola risque si rien
n'est fait de ne plus laisser beaucoup
de choix les engagements du nouveau
gouvernement en la matière n'ont pas
encore été tenue à savoir la nomination
par le gouvernement d'une commission
ayant pouvoir de décision pour organiser
l'enseignement public s'emballe